attablés en terrasse ou circulant dans
les rues masque sur le visage les
habitants de lérida ne semble pas encore
concernés par un possible reconfirme ans
de leur ville alors que le nombre de cas
de kovy 19 repart à la hausse en
catalogne
le gouvernement local a décidé d'imposer
de nouvelles restrictions de déplacement
dans cette zone située à 150 km à
l'ouest de barcelone mais le tribunal
supérieur de catalogne a refusé de
valider cette mesure qu'il juge
contraire au droit
une décision de justice qui n'altère pas
la détermination du gouvernement local
étant donné que nous n'acceptons pas la
décision judiciaire le gouvernement de
la généralité prend l'initiative dans
les prochaines heures sous la
supervision d'un conseil exécutif
extraordinaire d'approuver un décret
pour établir un plan de résurgence et
pour pouvoir agir avec toute la force
nécessaire dans tous les coins du pays
en fonction des chiffres de l'évolution
épidémiologique ce bras de fer
judiciaire se joue sur fond de défiance
persistante entre les autorités
catalanes et le gouvernement central
pour le ministre espagnol de la santé
les nouveaux foyers de contamination ne
nécessite pas de réimposer un
confinement à la population locale nous
sommes en contact direct et permanent
avec les autorités sanitaires du
gouvernement catalan et même s'il n'ya
pas d'autorisation du juge
nous sommes conscients que leurs
services juridiques travail pour voir
comment ils peuvent obtenir
l'autorisation de prendre des mesures
adéquates à la réalité de l'épidémie
leur permettant de contrôler l'épidémie
dans la région de ses grilles à face à
cette bataille judiciaire de nombreux
habitants de lérida se disent inquiets à
lérida il ya des secteurs qui ne sont
pas contrôlés
cela crée une insécurité les gens
commencent à perdre le sommeil parce
qu'ils ont peur la peur nous touche en
ce moment on devrait aussi équiper
davantage d'hôpitaux embaucher plus de
professionnels et et c'est tout le monde
et ensuite dire s'il faut confiné ou pas
maintenant comme il nous confine ça sera
pire parce qu'on va encore tout fermé et
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on relèvera la
tête
la catalogne n'est pas la seule région
espagnole à être concernée par de
nouveaux foyers de contagion
plus de 120 autres sont actifs
actuellement dans le pays pour faire
face la plupart des régions impose le
port du masque à tout moment dans la rue
comme dans les espaces publics fermés
la pandémie de coronavirus ça fait à ce
jour plus de 28000 400 morts en espagne